georgy zhukov was born into extreme
poverty but ended up as the commanding
general in charge of the entire Red Army
during World War two
today he is still considered by many in
Russia to be the greatest military minds
in their entire history Georgy Zhukov
was born in 1896 to an incredibly poor
peasant family in the Kaluga province
roughly 80 miles from Moscow his family
had a house in the relatively poor town
of strelkov cow which Zhukov was once
quoted as saying look to the West in his
village the family was rather tough when
it came to discipline and floggings with
a belt by his father Constantine were
quite common in order to with his boy
into the shape that he wanted however
young Zhukov was not one to complain
about things he felt that a hard life at
a young age was one of the best teachers
possible and hard life was something he
certainly had he had one older sister
named Maria that almost grew up with the
younger brother as well unfortunately
his brother Alexei did not live past a
year and his mother
Austin iya was absolutely heartbroken
then at the tender age of nine his life
changed drastically in order to provide
for his future and probably also to have
one less mouth to feed
his family sent him off to work for his
uncle Mikhail in Moscow as an apprentice
furrier while there was still a pretty
harsh life and beatings what comment if
he didn't do what he was supposed to do
he was still in a much better position
relatively than he had been before he
wasn't quite as poor he was exposed to
Moscow society and he had a lot more
education than he would have had
otherwise in the year 1920 Zhukov had
his first marriage to a woman named
Alexandra Davina Zhukova who he would
eventually have two daughters with named
era and Ella
however Zhukov was not entirely faithful
to his wife during his first marriage in
the early years he had an affair with a
young woman named Maria volkova who yet
met while laid up in the hospital while
in the Army during World War one they
add an illegitimate child together names
margarita but this didn't seem to have
any real effect on Zhukov's reputation
at the time or at any point in his
career in fact
indeed later on in life he got divorced
and remarried a woman who was called
Galina Alexandrovna semyonova and they
had a daughter together called Maria
which was his fourth and his last child
Zhukov was actually doing quite well as
a young man recently into adulthood
working as a furrier with a few young
men under him but when World War one
broke out and Russia needed able-bodied
men to come to the defense of their
country Zhukov was conscripted into the
army although no account says that he
had any complaints about being drafted
and he quickly found himself in an
advanced training program likely because
he was a little bit more educated than
most he got to start out training as
cavalry and quickly rose up the ranks to
corporal during World War II he even
managed to earn the cross of st. George
twice Russian military honor awarded for
bravery from lower ranking or
noncommissioned officers one award was
for his capture of a German soldier ins
another was for taking a grenade
explosion that left him in the hospital
for most of the rest of the war because
he was in fact taken out of the war so
early due to injury he never really felt
that his part in it was at all
significant Zhukov
having gone through so much poverty in
his early life had never really been a
fan of the Tsar's or the old political
system so when things started shaking up
in Russia he found himself fighting the
old system when the tsar nicholas ii
abdicated things were in chaos and a
provisional government took over
yoki and the soldiers working with him
decided to refuse to obey this new
government and was soon branded as
deserters and they ended up on the run
however once the Bolsheviks seized power
Zhukov was once again able to leave the
shadows and join up with them as a
soldier after several years of
participating in mopping up actions
against various rebel factions he
decided to join the Communist Party in
order to further his career his steady
hand as a commander as well as his
background of poverty made him a great
asset for the new regime and his star
continued to rise as he rose up the
ranks in the military he became more
well known but his most decisive early
action was a situation most people
aren't aware of in World War one in
which two years before the Germans
actually declared war on the Soviet
Union the Russians already had their
hands full with the Japanese the
Japanese have been adventuring into
Russian territory for some decades and
the Russians had been struggling to push
them back out the Japanese even reached
so close that they could almost disrupt
the crucial trans-siberian railway
Japanese wanted more land and more oil
and at the time they saw expansion into
Russia as the best option to achieve
their goals
the Japanese had been having border
clashes a Russian allied territory
basically trying to sneak through their
weakest points for almost a year when
Zhukov who had been given command of the
Soviet forces finally readied for his
first offensive where the Japanese had
amassed as the Galkin gold River he
amassed over 200 artillery pieces over
500 planes and almost 500 tanks he had
the greatest armored offensive in known
human history and in one big push
started borrowing the Japanese position
with bombers following this there was an
artillery barrage and then tanks finally
encircling the enemy to the point that
almost no one escaped this secure
zhukov's reputation is a great leader
able to move incredible amounts of new
armored units effectively and earned him
special attention from Soviet High
Command there are some people who argue
that Zhukov exaggerated his role in the
Battle of Kalkan Gaul and other battles
as well in order to aggrandize himself
and that he got away with it because the
Soviet Union wanted a standard verum and
because he managed to get along well
with Stalin one researcher named Suvarov
who has written critically of Zhukov
claims that the real credit for the
strategy at the Battle of kalkan goal
should have gone to his chief of staff a
brigade commander named na Bogdanov it
was often considered to be the greatest
leader that the Soviet Union had at the
time he also laments that most of the
first officers or other lesser leaders
involved seemed to still be classified
as if the Soviet Union wanted all the
credit to go to Zhukov however apart
from the fact that ma Bogdanov was a
great leader at the time there is no
reason to believe Zhukov didn't plan or
make his own decisions in the battle he
was the acting commander after all
despite criticisms and claims of proper
credit he became Stalin's favorite
general and despite occasional
disagreements he quickly became Stalin's
quasi-official
second-in-command for the rest of the
war now of course there were some major
faults that Zuko
as a military leader mainly he could
often be seen getting very angry using a
lot of foul language and being abusive
with people however this was not
entirely uncommon for a lot of military
leaders of the day and there is reason
to believe that his men respected him
because he actually valued their lives
one thing many people like to talk about
about the Soviet Union is the casual
disregard that they had for the lives of
their soldiers for example they're just
thrown masses of infantry at fortified
positions with no proper strategy and
Zhukov got a lot of blame for this as
the commander however he criticized
these tactics and indeed said that it
was criminal to throw lives away in such
a way and in another bit of writing he
was a little bit less critical sounding
but pointed out that skill and tactics
would win Wars not throwing the people
meat at the enemy general Zhukov became
very close to Stalin over the course of
World War two at least as closest you
can get to a brutal dictator and he
gained a certain respect for him while
Zhukov may have been more critical of
Stalin's influence and style of
leadership in his later life and memoirs
at the time he had nothing but good
things to say and seems to at least be
mostly enamored by Stalin's growing cult
of personality over the course of
roughly 120 in-person meetings he got to
know the man and felt that he had a good
measure of him some people thought that
Stalin could be too angry or too moody
but Zhukov seemed to prefer this he felt
that Stalin's show of anger of
frustration and other emotions were just
an example of him being exactly the sort
of straight shooter that Zhukov wanted
to work with he also felt that when
Stalin was not Moody he was very
analytical and was always willing to
listen to all viewpoints or hear an
argument against his own ideas in order
to better understand the situation in
fact Zhukov knew Stalin so well that he
was said to be able to gauge his moods
and thus how to react by how Stalin
handled his smoking pipe if stalin was
smoking slowly taking long luxurious
drags from his pipe it usually meant he
was in a particularly good mood however
if he didn't refill his pipe and get it
going again quickly when he was out it
meant it was about to get very very
angry
Zhukov used these signs to help him know
how to talk to Stalin even when he was
in a very bad mood at the Battle for
Berlin general Zhukov was in charge of
the first the
rushon France and urged his men to exact
a terrible vengeance on the Germans they
were entirely successful and finally
defeating the Germans that also in terms
of their vengeance as a Russian front
moved into Germany from the east they
brought terror upon civilians wherever
they went with looting and rapes being
especially common often the Battle of
Berlin general Zhukov was given the
honour of presiding over the Soviet
victory parade in Moscow in 1945 which
he happily took part in before being
sent back to preside as the commander in
charge of the Soviet occupied Germany
Zhukov was quickly using his post as
military governor to become good friends
with other world leaders like Eisenhower
and increases influence abroad by doing
a really good job of taking care of
civilians in the aftermath of World War
two in Germany Stalin quickly became
paranoid that Zhukov would become a
political or a military threat to him
and removed him from this post bringing
him back home to face charges of
disloyalty Stalin was himself a military
commander but from a day when there was
no mechanized warfare
even though Zhukov was no real threat as
he never had the political chops of
Stalin he was seen as a threat because
he had an understanding of this sort of
warfare and a certain popularity within
the military this was something that
Stalin would always be jealous of
when Stalin started to fear general
Zhukov at the end of the war he decided
to make an example out of him but not
too big of one considering his
popularity Stalin did not think it wise
to kill arrest or punish him too harshly
but he wanted to put him firmly in his
place upon his return to Moscow he was
raked over the coals and privately
accused of disloyalty to the party in
order to take away his ability to
potentially take over the government his
position as commander-in-chief of the
military forces it was taken away and he
was sent off to a secondary position in
a deaths are a much smaller command far
from Moscow where he suffered his first
heart attack not long after he found
himself back in Moscow for a time but
the venturi barrier Stalin's radically
loyal security chief was trying to find
a way to destroy him berry had never
trusted a man with so much military
power and believed he could be a
dangerous threat to the cult of Stalin
barrier finally searched Zuko's
apartment in 1948 and found a huge trove
of treasures that Zhukov had taken back
from Soviet occupied Germany without
telling anyone
despite his popularity it was a big hit
to his reputation and Zhukov was forced
to publicly apologize before finding
himself being sent to an even more
insulting and pathetic position in the
urals district while Zhukov's life may
have taken quite a bad turn after the
war it could have been worse barrier
likely would have had him arrested or
executed if he could but Stalin was not
really interested in going that far
against Zhukov whether for personal or
politically pragmatic reasons
Levin tree barrier was one of Stalin's
most radical followers so when Stalin
died in 1953 many of the top leaders of
the Soviet Union were struggling to
decide who would be the one in power and
a group of small conspirators worked
together
to overthrow the last of Stalin's main
influence in order to destroy a barrier
Malenkov Molotov and Khrushchev met with
Zhukov and hatched a plan to arrest him
that would be a major party meeting with
many high-profile members and at the
right moment sukhov would come in with a
few military officers and arrest barrier
the arrest it went off without any hitch
at all and very it was taken away to be
accused formerly of terrorism and
counter-revolutionary activities judged
officially and then shot for his crimes
Zhukov likely played
a large portion if not all of the blame
for the horrible positions he had been
increasingly relegated to you after
Stalin's death as well as the horrific
embarrassment of the trophy affair on
the shoulders of barrier while Zhukov
did like to think he was getting rid of
the influence of the cult of Stalin and
likely told himself that was part of his
justification
he must have certainly got a lot of
personal satisfaction out of the man's
destruction even once said that a
resting barrier was the greatest thing
he had ever done in his life while all
his looting from the trophy affair
wasn't exactly a great thing to do it is
understandable for him to harbor
resentment at having his loot taken away
and being forced to apologize for it as
that kind of looting was quite common
among the Soviet leadership after World
War two after the death of Stalin and
the arrest of barrier leading to the end
of Stalin's cult of personality
Zhukov soon found himself appointed as
Minister of Defense under Nikolai
Bulganin during these years he tried to
foster peace between the United States
the Soviet Union and the rest of the
world being reluctant to take military
action and less absolutely necessary
this partly stems from long
conversations that he had with dry D
Eisenhower with whom he had struck up a
friendship years previously at the end
of World War two Zhukov took Eisenhower
on a tour of the Soviet Union and an
Eisenhower even invited Zhukov to
America although he was not allowed to
go on such a tour the two of them talked
a lot and even corresponded through
letters for years after after meeting
with Zhukov and getting to know him so
well Eisenhower actually believed that
true and lasting peace with the Soviet
Union was entirely possible and he hoped
that his relationship with Zhukov and
Zhukov's influence in governments and
with the Russian people would help to
make that happen
unfortunately Zhukov was such a
reformist and continued to take power to
himself in such a way that those in
charge became increasingly worried about
him when Zhukov wrote extremely
critically of the cult of Stalin
denouncing the way the government used
to be run under the old dictator wily
old Khrushchev used Zhukov statements
and popularity to institute real reforms
with himself as the head but at the same
time he was worried about Zhukov the
former general Linz now Minister of
Defense was asking soldiers to go to him
first before any of the politicians and
Khrushchev had him removed
Minister of Defense in 1958 for fear of
him becoming a Bonaparte Asst after how
badly Napoleon had thrashed them
relatively recently in their history the
Russians feared a leader who would take
over from within using the military and
then run the country by military dictate
politicians like Khrushchev believes
that Zhukov was loyal and they loved to
use the popularity that he had with the
people but they found these same traits
dangerous to the continued political
rule of their country unfortunately
Zhukov had a history of being used by
politicians to achieve their own ends
and then being thrown aside later it's
hard to say if this kept happening
simply because Zhukov was hoping to gain
more political power that simply did not
have the political skills or whether he
knew he was unlikely to gain any real
power but simply did what he thought was
best for the country at the time
regardless it would likely be quite a
different world if Zhukov had had the
political skills to truly advance in the
power structure that emerged in the
Soviet Union after World War two if he
were to have taken control his
relationship with Eisenhower might have
helped to bridge the divide between the
two countries since history might have
turned out very very differently however
things were not all bad with Khrushchev
in control until the end of his
Premiership in 1964 Khrushchev was a
tireless reformer who got rid of a lot
of the repressive Stalinist policies and
tried to bring more art and creativity
back to the country again when Brezhnev
came to power in 1964 he also saw Zhukov
as so many had before him as someone he
could use while Zhukov had been largely
ignored under Khrushchev it was under
the Premiership of Brezhnev that he was
allowed to publish his memoirs after
properly groveling to the latest leader
of the country of course he also had his
public image greatly rehabilitated by
Brezhnev in order to shore up his own
popularity while Brezhnev used Zhukov
for his popularity he did not trust him
in politics after all of the accusations
have been a part ISM over the years and
apart from writing his memoirs Zhukov
would remain retired for the rest of his
remaining years when Zhukov retired his
thoughts went to write his memoirs and
he started working on reminisces and
reflections he also spent a lot of time
just relaxing hunting and socializing
with
we used to know as he wrote his memoirs
however his health continued to steadily
decline his bouts with heart disease
earlier in life were a sign of things to
come and in 1967 Zhukov had another
heart attack that hit him so hard it
took away the use of the left side of
his body for his remaining years during
his struggle with heart disease his wife
Galina was attending to Emmons trying to
help him get his memoirs finished
finally in 1969 they were completed past
the censors and published they became
the most popular accounts of the war
from a Soviet perspective selling
millions of copies around the world fan
letters and suggestions poured into
Zhukov's mailbox in the tens of
thousands wishing him well and praising
him for his life's loyal work
unfortunately for Zhukov this resurgence
of his old popularity it was not to be
enjoyed for long in 1973
his second wife Galina passed away and
Zhukov was left entirely alone his
memoirs were published his life's work
was done his children were accounted for
and his wife was gone without her
physical and emotional support and with
years of heart disease building up he
didn't outlast her by long in 1974 a
final heart attack took him and the
Soviet Union lost their greatest
military hero of the age when Zhukov
died he was given a state funeral led by
Brezhnev who had his ashes laid to rest
in honor at the Kremlin wall zhukov's
legacy will always enjoy some
controversy but there is no doubt that
he was one of the greatest military
minds of World War two and one of the
greatest men of the Soviet Union so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a like below and don't forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this a couple of times a week
looking at all sorts of people from
history not just military leaders but
running the gamut of a bunch of people
so subscribe to that and hit that bell
so you actually find out about our
videos if you want to watch something
right now although check out one of the
other videos we're linking to on the
screen now and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]